it's creepy mask
that was an animal did you see that hand
dear that was an a difficult term that
was an animal as well it's one of person
so we have three separate killers we've
got the guy that likes chasing animals
this thing that's a cottonmouth
that's like some kind of Boxster and
we've got the actual killer there's
three separate things trying to kill us
so you think the guy that's following
and the guy that's doing all the other
stuff this ain't possible to say I
managed to hide an event someone this
chat is called with violence sounds fun
that sounds really fun more upset I'm
really worried about Sam I feel like
she's a main character but maybe she
lost him to me
she needs to she's she's a good person
yeah I think they intentionally make her
a favorite and you know what I like my
canal so I might want to do beforehand I
wish that she had some clothes on and
all that these tell them I know I think
that it'd be really good just to be
changed or what is she trying to go
where she may be one person - because I
think there's a soul thing a shredder
yes I do
this is file uh-huh there's nothing I'll
see you gonna open it
there we go yeah it still good fishing
you go squirrel hunting happiness Josh
Josh that's Joey's psychiatric
evaluation after incidents off -
disagreement over treatment response to
drugs
what badly side effects will be coming
to severe drug there's no one having an
affect mood had badly wasn't maybe this
is after they died he became depressed
or something we didn't think he was a
good person you know it's a slide - yeah
I know Adrian
maybe he um summery depressive
yeah related to death appearances it's
just if that makes sense
yeah that's how we make sense so maybe
that's why he's [ __ ] up is if you use
to Preston's on drugs yeah that makes me
feel bad
yeah it wasn't his fault that I thought
he was very cute him anyway why didn't
mean to kill him throw it away
know who didn't wait to kill any man
Chris yeah we just had I can't believe
the way that Matt died I'm Mike I'm mad
about that we mister I just can't
it was and I thought what because it
gave us the choice twice to save Emily
or John I don't want to jump to safety
they listen because you lied about all
that life sir oh no that's not your
fault I told I kept a letter so numerous
boards
so whoever did this has made out aboard
to Beth and Hanna yeah it also doesn't
file up to offer you so he cares about
banking where does care of it but there
was that list that thing that semi
waited for 42 years to something like
that white skin remember that dance rush
so that could be like timing you
somewhere for some reason like should I
run in a different rooms in this place
yeah it's huge and it's like seven
different things on the mountain
yeah and you didn't know that so [ __ ]
right there
Oh watching everything he's got cameras
yeah we're leaving honey I think that
he'll come over to me and by watching
for too long he's gone is he's gone a
minute
he's [ __ ] gone he's gonna oh my god
oh [ __ ] she should be taken to a victim
as to what he's watching
no it's noisy that's true
that's Josh that's [ __ ] Josh that's
Josh
it was pre-recorded just killed himself
that was absolutely Josh's voice that
was pre-recorded so that thing that was
played when Josh and Ashley were in the
room was pre-recorded Josh's voice while
Josh was hanging there so - Josh [ __ ]
kill himself j9 it was that was
absolutely oh my god what does that say
in the menu that people in recording it
sounds like this like rehearsing speech
so oh my god what does that mean I
thought the judge was a debit he but he
died right plus the we [ __ ] life you
don't I just feel like I did her in his
I was so convincing instead that he
didn't die though
yeah I think it has to be it has to be I
just think that I do I was sucking that
she was the bad guy but I feel like he
couldn't be dead and that was [ __ ]
him is very shadow rehearsing his speech
yes and that was Josh yep josh Josh -
yeah but that was pre-recorded he
prerecorded when he said to Chris and
you think I mean he also pre-recorded
the part that said I see you have chosen
to save actually that was a tape so that
whole thing was planned by Josh he's
Josh bed now I just I mean you know I
find it I don't know how you could do
some kids it's hanging out I don't know
how you had like that a lot I don't know
how you could like that but it is well
maybe there's my baby he was willingly
died in this to kill us or something
I have no idea yeah it's the cameras in
fact yes monka Beth it's not like okay
welcome look at that I can't believe
that that was absolutely Josh he's
[ __ ] pre-planned all of this and I'm
really worried about her right now
somehow this is the person actually
there she's in the same area same but
that's opposed it did buddy though
pretend Italy wait that's the thing that
they tricked them into thinking was
saying and that was supposed to be
saying it wasn't you suck what how'd she
take a closer Chris Chris Chris Taylor
Mike which one shocked no fingers what
okay
you finally got his fingers up I'm
curious would be huh hell did you get in
here yeah each one Jerry's new canvas
opinion yeah yeah how did you get there
did she don't realize that was his job
it's not really my caddy to get here
it's difficult Josh does but that was
dumb [ __ ] jokes on record I don't
know what that means
just get to Norfolk please - just
I just I feel like many processes
information that was Josh or processed
and process that was Josh that was was
totally Josh I'm not worried about that
only what isn't that what I get with
smart Josh Josh kill - the other
backpacks ain't gorgeous or something
else at least now he didn't kill Josh we
can write that one off the list he
killed himself
that's why I'm glad you do you've got
that I mean I wasn't really either but I
feel like we've been terrible at this in
that we killed so many people I think we
had I mean we didn't kill me on we
didn't kill him
so we've only killed Matt and Jess real
and Josh killed himself
however and then who the [ __ ] are sodium
wants to manage I can't believe you like
thinking about as much liar
no because I'm not I just really want to
get away from Spencer this is a plot
twist oh is that really Mike he is
missing the fingers I'm only confused
because how did he get here yeah just
putting clothes on then around awkwardly
in the midst of nearly dying dr. Nyland
no no idea
that's just why have you trying to make
him look awkward or uncomfortable and
not doing a great job of it I'm glad
that you do I really I'm done I think
everyone should stick together where
possible and I want these guys to go
find action Chris that's what that
nights we've just been
yes blanks they went from your bullets
[ __ ] chalky knew it we knew and they
will never see it they have to explain
that maybe we've thought that he was
creepy any work and I'd be on the
courses no I okay no no this means he
hasn't actually killed anyone
Josh hasn't killed anyone he's just been
freaking them out if that gun had blanks
in it do you think that stopped it that
had nothing to do with Josh josh hasn't
killed anyone
Josh she's just trying to freak them out
and doing an excellent job
you didn't kill Jess that was like a
creepy monster and that other guy was
there how do you know we saw lots of
guts and stuff so so we don't believe
any of it
no no it's just none of it had anything
to do with Josh you know we just I just
wasn't there just with a mouse
she was still at the hell are you
following me penny my thinking Jess
isn't it
no Jesse's Tim but who is this job not
okay good I'm thinking your future
almost killed so I like one of those
weird things yes I killed Matt yeah like
monsters Josh didn't kill anyone
we thought that he was gonna kill ash or
Josh
really him that's right he hasn't kill
anyone he's just been [ __ ] with them
so he hasn't even done anything wrong
you didn't kill anyone